young is in Virginia young what's up hi
Dave thanks for taking my call sure not
gonna help ya I wanted to ask you two
quick question one is whether I should
sell my house or not I'm currently in
baby step two I have about thirty eight
thousand dollars of debt and my wife
will end up with about three hundred
fifty thousand dollars of student loan
debt from dental school
oh the complicated parties all my
parents are living in my house right now
and my my wife is leaving about 60 miles
away from from me or she'll be done with
school in nine months and at that point
I'm wondering if I should sell my house
and the really start from scratch oh oh
using whatever money comes from this
from the sale to on to to pay off our
debt yeah what do you make about 105
here 105 K so she'll probably come out
and make a hundred 150 roughly but not
buying into a practice and so you'd have
a 200 to 250 to work on the debt
what's the equity in your home yeah I
ask maybe on like 40 50 40 to 50 mm-hm
and what do you owe on it oh all about
three hundred thousand okay so yeah it
was very normal
yeah so the 40 the forty to fifty
doesn't really help that much getting
rare three hundred thousand does
depending on where where are you guys
anticipating living so we're trying to
stay pretty close to here or if we've
been going to this church for a while I
know we want to speak to try to stay
close to church
oh yeah the the complicated part right
now is because my current went through a
lot so they are living in my house right
now for free
oh well you know I I've made my parents
pay some of the utility or some
insurance and a few things but you had
the mortgage it on me right now
mm-hm oh and so once I move out of the
house with my with my wife then oh no oh
you know you'll be very hard for them to
be self reliable self-reliant okay well
we got to get that going that mean
that's because I don't see you putting
your parents into the street as homeless
people yeah I know so um you know we
have to work on a plan to you know a
12-month plan for them to get in a
situation where they're sustainable so
what is their income oh I think they do
about about 40 about 50,000 together
50,000 together okay and how old are
they tearing they are late sixties all
right okay and so making if they make
$50,000 a year why can they not rent a
small apartment Oh lots of people only
thousand dollars a year dude oh yeah
that make sense dude would the one thing
is because again my work is here in
Virginia and my wife goes to dental
school in Baltimore and I'm not able to
stay with her the whole time I'm leaving
here in Virginia I have to house I'm
living with my parents well my parents
are living with me and so I understand
I'm just saying nine months from now
when you need to sell the house we have
to have a plan for them to have a life
that's not that doesn't involve
homelessness and so we need to start
talking about that with them now so that
it doesn't sneak up on them I mean you
and I've already had more of a
conversation than you and them probably
yeah yeah so you need to sit down with
him tonight go mom and dad look when my
wife graduates in nine months we've got
to get this house sold because we can't
afford it because she's got a big pile
of student loan debt and we've got to
get that dug through and so we've got to
start talking about where you guys are
gonna live in nine months and you know I
want to help you I'm not gonna just dump
you in the street but we've got to start
developing together a game plan and I'm
gonna be your biggest cheerleader and
I'll even help you some but but this
house is no longer going to be in the
picture nine months from now so we got
to work together for a plan for you guys
okay if you said that conversation to
your mom and dad how would an opening
line how
that go ah it won't be easy I mean I
mean they expect you to care for them a
hundred percent for the rest of their
life well I hope the I don't think they
do the one thing is my my parents you
know one here I mean I I don't want to
take the other the back mirror view I
want to exceed windshield take every
windshield approach but my mother had
cancer and I bought my father went
through bankruptcy until that time I we
had to take out my grandmother who had a
stroke and all of that too
it's been a little messy up to now well
I think you can just say that to say
there's been a lot of pain and you guys
have been through a lot and again we're
gonna walk with you we're not dropping
you we love you but we also have to make
plans here for the future we can't just
sit here in this house it doesn't work
anymore after nine months and so um you
know II get you know I know mom's you
know I know the cancer thing still
scares you know dad you've been through
the bankruptcy I know losing grandmother
I know all of those things still hurt in
the midst of that we're still going to
have these discussions about how about
where we're all gonna live because I'm
not gonna be able to keep this house
because my wife is three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt and so we cannot repeat this
financial pain generationally so I have
to do something bad I mean and I can
help you guys I mean will help you we're
not we're but we're not gonna all just
pile in this house and live together and
try to make it work out and us take care
of you so you make you make enough money
to live and let's start getting on a
budget and huh you know let's go through
Financial Peace University together you
can walk and hold their hand and help
them make these decisions but if you're
not allowed to discuss this then you've
got family issues but if you're allowed
to discuss it gently kindly and firmly
then you've got a good healthy family
where you can have these discussions
sometimes culture plays into the
discussion the culture of some some
cultures are more you take care of your
parents than others no matter what no
matter how toxic or ridiculous the
situation is you're supposed to still
take care of your parents in certain
cultures
and so that you know and it's it's
guilt-tripped if you don't you know that
kind of thing so you got to deal with
all that but it's all right there in
front of you you can do it